hello my name is betsy espinal and this
is my final project
for genomics in the virtual lab and it
is titled
viruses as a cystic fibrosis cure and
this project
is building off of my last project that
i did which is just on cystic fibrosis
an introduction to cystic fibrosis
cystic fibrosis is a serious disease
that affects the lungs and digestive
system causing pancreatic insufficiency
and recurrent respiratory infections
it results from a deletion type mutation
in the cftr gene
this disease is most common in caucasian
populations and is autosomal recessive
there is currently no cure for cystic
fibrosis treatments include medicines to
help control symptoms prevent
complications and make the condition
easier to live with
prenatal screening is also an option for
parents of unborn children
this is the healthy cftr gene
the pdf code is 5uak
and it is pictured on the left in a
person without cystic fibrosis the
cystic fibrosis transmembrane regulator
protein functions
as a chloride ion channel that regulates
fluid in airways
and other regions the cftr gene is
located on chromosome 7.
as we can see on the left whenever the
protein is phosphorylated the channel
opens and allows
ions to pass through and this allows the
cell to regulate fluids
in the lungs and this is unhealthy cftr
gene which leads to an unhealthy cftr
protein
and the pdf code for this is
4wz6 most common mutation that leads to
cystic fibrosis
is called delta f508 this mutation
involves the deletion of three
nucleotides and causes 70
of all cystic fibrosis cases and on the
top left
i have a model of the two
cftr proteins on top of each other and
this region is just the regulatory
domain because that's where the
mutations occur
and the red parts are the mutations the
cftr protein in cystic fibrosis cannot
properly manage fluid regulation due to
its structure
in the regulatory domain which leads to
the channel not being able to open
when the regulatory domain is
phosphorylated so basically what happens
is the phosphate activates the
regulatory domain
that tells the channel to open but
in people with cystic fibrosis this
doesn't happen because of mutations that
happen in the regulatory domain and this
leads to
lots of problems for someone diagnosed
with cystic fibrosis dealing with this
disease can be extremely
emotionally distressing patients face
low life expectancy
the life expectancy is only 37 years
chronic symptoms and decreasing bodily
function that causes disability
as patients enter adulthood their
emotional well-being is known to
decrease as their condition becomes more
severe
because of the disease's specific nature
there has been no success curing it
so what is the solution for a disease
this serious it is very clear that
treating the symptoms has its limits
it is necessary to tackle the issue at
the genetic level using gene therapy
what is gene therapy and could it cure
cystic fibrosis
gene therapy introduces healthy genetic
material into cells in order to correct
abnormalities that cause disease
vectors are the carriers of this genetic
material they're usually modified
viruses
so in this diagram it shows a virus
carrying the cftr
gene it would infect the person through
the respiratory tract
enter the lungs infect the cells with
the protein
and deliver the therapeutic genes that
would in theory cure the person
cystic fibrosis was one of the first
targets of gene therapy
when the practice picked up viability
two decades ago
however there has been no lasting
success so far targeting the lungs is
particularly tricky because our lungs
are evolved to be extremely virus
resistant
even though our lungs are this way we
know that viruses like coronaviruses
influenza adenoviruses lentiviruses
and others do succeed in causing
respiratory illness
could we use one of these as a vector
and cure cystic fibrosis
so obviously my answer to that would be
yes we probably could
and out of the viruses listed in the
last
slide adenoviruses and lentiviruses are
the most promising
and here's why so both of them do really
well
in terms of the four main categories
that are considered
when looking at possible vectors and
these are duration of expression
targeted cells packaging capacity and
immunogenic potential
for adenovirus vectors it is
transient which means it doesn't
integrate into the genome
and for the lentivirus it it does
integrate into the genome which makes it
in theory a permanent solution while the
adenovirus would need to be
re just reapplied targeted cells both of
them
are respiratory and widespread meaning
they could
infect the respiratory cells and also
other cells
in the body packaging capacity this is
how much
space the vector has to hold therapeutic
gene material
and for the adenovirus it is 7.5
kb which stands for kilobases and for
the lentivirus
it is 9.7 kilobases the immunogenic
potential
means how likely is it to trigger a
immune response like anaphylaxis
in the patient that is given to and
obviously we don't want that to happen
because that's very dangerous
and the adenovirus factor it's
considered pretty high
and for the lentivirus it's considered
relatively low
so even though both candidates are
promising lentivirus is the most
promising
due to its long-term expression slightly
larger packaging potential
and low probability of immune response
but putting it together
the healthy cftr gene is approximately
189
kb in length which greatly exceeds the
9.7 kb packaging capacity
luckily studies suggest that only 5 to
10 percent of normal cfdr gene
is required to reverse disease effect
and this is because only this region of
the protein
is not functioning the rest of it is
okay and we don't need to
use precious space in the packaging
capacity
to store this information when it's
already okay
we need this information and that only
accounts for
five to ten percent um so the mutated
cftr gene is in the section that codes
for the regulatory domain
which is called ndb1 and is located on
exon 9. so this region is the region we
want to take that
5 to 10 percent because this region
codes for this region which is the
problem we only have
9.7 kb from exon 9
and that accounts for 5.15
of the normal cftr gene which does fall
into the range
of what is considered
enough to reverse the disease effect so
yes
the lentivirus does have enough space
and it might be able to hold all the
information needed to reverse the
disease's effect
so summary cystic fibrosis is a serious
disease of the transmembrane proteins
involved in chloride ion transport it is
currently incurable
and that's really why i wanted to look
into cures or possible cures for
my final project healthy cftr proteins
are able to open
after the nbd1 region of the protein is
phosphorylated but in people with the
delta
f508 mutation this region is deformed
and unable to open using gene therapy
this illness
may be able to be cured the ideal viral
vector for the delivery of the
therapeutic gene would be a modified
lentivirus because of its duration of
expression
packaging capacity and low immunogenic
potential
modifying a lentivirus and packaging it
with genetic material from
exon 9 might be able to cure cystic
fibrosis and there's my project
so what i learned is all about
viral vectors because i knew about them
and i knew about their use
in gene therapy but i didn't really know
why we chose the viruses
that scientists choose and why they're
able to
be effective it's really interesting to
research
all about that and also there are
promising studies
using the lentivirus in humans to cure
cystic fibrosis but up until now
there hasn't been a total cure but it is
looking
like lunch virus might be the way to go
and now that i've done my own research
into why that is and why it makes sense
i understand here
is my links for raw data and
reference publications and that was my
presentation thank you for watching